HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So
first of all, can you
give me your short
introduction to what
you're doing, what are
the business doing,
and then what is your
go global strategy?
From probably, Mor?
Yeah.
MOR SHANI: I'm Mor,
from Jelly Button Games.
I'm one of the
co-founders and the CEO.
Our main business is
casual, free to play games.
Our first hit is
"Pirate King," which
currently has around 50 million
of downloads till today.
And we're still going global.
This is more or less.
You want to talk-- what
do you want to talk?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Well,
how about go global stuff,
as you're trying to go global?
Or we should talk later?
MOR SHANI: Yeah, I think so.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Let's talk later.
OK, Massimo?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Hi, everybody.
My name is Massimo, although
everybody calls me Max.
Easier.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Oh really?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Yeah.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
I didn't know that.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Much easier.
I'm the co-founder
and CEO of Musixmatch.
Musixmatch is the world's
largest database of lyrics.
I'm not a singer, unfortunately.
And we have, so far, more
than 50 million downloads
everywhere.
And thanks for inviting me.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Thank you.
Andres?
ANDRES BOU: I'm Andres.
I'm CEO and co-founder
of Socialpoint.
We are a gaming company
based in Barcelona.
So we are most known because
of "Dragon City" and "Monster
Legends."
And to give you some
numbers, "Dragon City"
has been downloaded more
than 150 million times.
And we are quite global, also.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
[INAUDIBLE]?
GILBERT WEDAM:
[INAUDIBLE] Hello?
Is the mic on?
REGINA CHAMMA: No.
GILBERT WEDAM: Is that OK?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
[INAUDIBLE] Working.
GILBERT WEDAM: One, two-- one,
two-- one, two-- one-- one,
two?
Hello?
Hello.
I'm Gil.
I lead design at Citymapper.
It's a transport app
specifically built
for the city.
So we take all the
crazy data that's
out there, try to
make sense for it,
and build and design
a product around it
basically for you to find
out how to get from A
to B. We're currently live in
30 cities and 10 countries.
Yeah.
REGINA CHAMMA: Hello,
my name is Regina.
I lead Google Play BD for
Latin America, especially
Brazil and Mexico.
And it's a pleasure to be here.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
So let's get
started discussions.
But I would like to make more
like interactive the session
here.
So I will shoot one
questions to you guys,
then make them
more interactions.
Then ask the audience if
you have any questions,
then please jump in.
All right.
So first of all, I would
like to ask about here,
what is your global
strategy actually?
Then what is your challenge
in the global market?
If you go into there, then
what was your challenges?
OK, so Gil?
GILBERT WEDAM: Basically,
as you can probably imagine,
we're very-- like localization
is the key thing we
have to figure out.
Our strategy has always
been to localize the product
very heavily.
So whenever we launch a city,
we hand design all the transport
icons.
We travel a lot to the cities.
We have people taking care
of specifically one city.
So also, culturally, it's
been always the humor,
the tone of the app.
Also, when we
localize strings, it's
very important to really
understand the local tone.
We partly solve that by hiring
people that speak the language
and come from these
regions, so it's
kind of an in-house
sort of-- that's
when it gets the most natural.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Like a native check?
GILBERT WEDAM: Sorry?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Native
check in your company?
GILBERT WEDAM: Yeah.
Yeah.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Cool.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA:
OK, I'll go too.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Go ahead.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA:
For us, localization,
it's everything, because when
we talk about music and lyrics,
we're talking
about a huge space.
To provide you some numbers,
the number of unique music
tracks in the world,
unique-- so they are unique
just once in an album--
it's around 4 million.
Out of that, 60% of them
are mainly English track.
But then there's a huge, long
tail with Spanish, Chinese,
Japanese, Indian, Portuguese,
Italian, German, French,
and whatever.
So we have actually-- you
know we're a database--
we do cover-- we have to cover,
so for us, the localization
is a must.
I mean, we do cover more
than 80 different languages,
in terms of content.
So the challenge for
us is-- Musixmatch
is a crowd-sourced platform.
So the more we
grow in a country,
the more-- you
mentioned Japan before.
Japan, it's been incredibly
important for us,
because the more we
were growing there,
the more the Japanese users
were adding the content.
So we give the
power to the users
to add the localized content.
So what I want to
share is that, if you
run content inside your
app, whatever you do,
from lyrics, whatever, your
content must be localized,
must be offered.
Which doesn't mean, as you
say, just translate your app.
You have the issue of
offering your local content.
Brazilian, typically, they
like certain kind of music,
different from German people.
And US, different
from Japanese people.
So for us, it's really a must
to get the local content,
plus ensuring the local rights.
Because we pay rights
holder in every single place
of the world, you know?
But I must say that it's kind
of key challenge and strategy
for us.
Without that, we couldn't really
be present in any country.
Like, for us, being in Japan
without having Japanese lyrics,
it's kind of--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So first,
you publish the application,
then you don't localize
to Japanese, right?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: In
general, we don't--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I mean,
application-- store listing.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: I
mean, we don't localize
[INAUDIBLE] application.
Also, back to out
localize the application.
Our goal is we empower the
user to translate the app.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
Yes, the contents.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA:
Yeah, the content.
And also the app itself.
When they complain, they
say, can you help us?
So that's been
extremely important too,
besides using the app's
translator tool that you offer.
But we let them add the
local content, you know?
So I think that it's very
important to empower your user
and get suggestions
from your users.
And then, we try to listen to
any of them by analyzing data.
I think all of
you guys mentioned
a lot of things you can
do with Google Analytics.
I think that's a
key resource for us,
analyzing continuously data
from any single country.
I'm selling.
[LAUGHTER]
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
I would like
to move on-- the game side.
MOR SHANI: Yeah.
I will share a little
bit different aspect
that we are having.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I have
questions for the game side.
MOR SHANI: All right.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I had a
talk about the culturalize--
or the going to market
was culturalized
or just localizations.
Then I'd like to
ask Mor and Andres
about how do you
think about-- you
like to go with original
APK in localized language?
Or separate APK to that market?
MOR SHANI: So first of
all, I think that everybody
wants to go global.
It's all about the
efforts, focus,
and of course, market
potential and costs.
CPIs are getting extremely high.
So as an early developer, you
have to be really focused,
and you really have to put
a lot of attention in that.
So I would say, when we
started "Pirate King," for us,
we had to think,
strategy-wise, how to reduce
the barrier of localization.
Because it was a very early
stage company and game
developer, and we couldn't
afford a lot of money
and a lot of marketing,
of course, expenses
into going global.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So
save the budget first.
MOR SHANI: Have to, if
you're an early developer.
So what we really believed
is focus on the product as
much as you can, and make it
seem as a beautiful experience
from the product sides.
So I would recommend for
everybody who wants to see,
there is a beautiful
lecture of George Fan,
which is the creator
of "Plants vs Zombies."
It's a little bit 2010, but
it's a beautiful lecture
about how he convinced his mom
to play "Plants vs Zombies."
And we were really
inspired by PopCap
and a lot of beautiful
process they made there.
And there, he speak
about a lot of how
to make this process of first
engagement and localization.
He has many tricks and
very beautiful things.
And even know to use more
than eight words, pop-ups.
And we understood that, if
we're an early stage developer,
we have to use as
much tricks as we can.
We got really inspired
from this process.
So in "Pirate King," we
embedded those processes.
Later on, of course,
we built a strategy
with the Google Play
team and, of course,
with our marketing team.
And gradually, we started in--
we're located in Tel Aviv,
Israel-- so we
started in Israel.
And then, we started
to grow in Singapore,
in Malaysia, in Thailand, and
all around Southeast Asia,
without localizing or culture.
People told us, you cannot
get into Thailand without
localizing or culturalizing.
And we said, we believe that
the product is everything.
And we believe that we can bring
this experience to our users.
So in our tipping
point, like in our top,
it was 450,000 of installs a
day, only from Southeast Asia.
And 70% of that was Google.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: You
localized the languages?
MOR SHANI: Nothing.
Nothing.
We only localized the souce--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Just
publish it in the English?
MOR SHANI: Yes.
And we a little bit
localize the stores.
We used a lot of content
community strategy.
We worked really close, of
course, with the Play team.
Very focused on the strategy.
And then combining it both,
it was very, very strong.
So as an early
developer in return--
it's really important to be
very focused on what you can do,
comparing to the
market, to the efforts.
And then you can combine
it to a beautiful strategy.
And now that we're
going global-- now
that we can afford going
global-- you really have to,
again, focus on the
emerging markets.
And of course, we're aiming
to Latin America, and the US,
and of course, Europe.
So for us, this journey
was very strong.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Cool.
How about Andres?
ANDRES BOU: For us, we always
launch the games globally.
So we check the boxes
of all the countries
around the world, huh?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
ANDRES BOU: And then, we launch
always with one single KPI,
just because it's easier
for us to manage it.
And then, depending
on the results
that we see on the KPIs--
[INAUDIBLE], monetization,
all the KPIs-- is
when we start doing
special focus on some markets.
So apart from the core
mechanics from the game,
we change many,
many other things.
We change the Play Store
art, we change the title
of the game, we market.
So we do special marketing
actions for each market
quite different
from one to another.
Obviously, we translate
with local partners.
We change the icon.
So we have different price
points for some markets.
And also, we do some
live vlogs or some offers
that are different from
one market to another.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Do
you have the office outside
of the Barcelona?
ANDRES BOU: What?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Do
you have an office outside
of the Barcelona?
ANDRES BOU: We are opening
an office in Tokyo.
We don't have anyone
physically there,
but we have Socialpoint
Tokyo company there.
But we are willing
to grow there.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So
we have only five minutes.
So do we have any questions
within the panelists?
If we don't have, then let's
move on to ask the audience.
Do we have any
questions in each other?
No?
No.
OK, let's move on
to ask the audience.
Any question to the panelists?
You can ask any questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: OK.
AUDIENCE: I've got a
question for you guys.
j changing icons globally,
like for localized markets,
do you guys ever worry about
keeping a consistent brand
for your developer company?
Is this something that
you guys have dealt with?
MALE SPEAKER: You mean
changing the brand?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If you change the
icon, it can obviously
change the perception
of the brand,
if it's not tied to your brand.
GILBERT WEDAM: Specifically,
for that reason,
we didn't touch the
icon, because it
is part of the brand.
And what we use A/B testing
a lot for is the screenshots.
And so we do a lot of
A/B testing on that.
But the icon, I think,
at least in our case--
maybe for games, it's
a bit different--
but for being a utility
app, I think the icon
is too much part of the brand.
But I do wish I could,
because I would be curious
if there were strong effects,
if we changed the icon.
But haven't done it.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: In my
case, I remember one example
that really scared me.
We use screenshot of the app,
which recalls the album's art.
So in that case, we
had Katy Perry images.
Obviously, all these things
we pay the rights for.
And she was in a bikini, but
it was not offending picture.
We got tons of complaints
by Arabian users.
And this was not anything we
had even planned, you know?
How could you plan?
How could you think you can
really offending people?
So at that point, we
started doing A/B tests
with all the screenshots, and
we saw these going much better.
I think it's like when you go
and you come in a country you
don't know, there might
be something that,
in terms, culturally different.
And this depends country
by country, you know?
So you have to deep understand.
But you should ask
your users, you know?
I mean, since you're growing so
fast, I would always ask users,
you know?
Get feedback from them.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
And then A/B testing.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: A/B testing.
Another thing's very
useful, I think,
which we should all be thankful
to Google is the beta testing.
I mean, we have
like, 15,000 beta--
I say we have 15,000
employee for free,
people testing your app
immediately since you release,
and providing you feedback.
That's kind of amazing.
But not all apps are using that.
ANDRES BOU: For us, we
have changed the icon.
I mean, for example,
"Monster Legends,"
we have changed the
icon between-- for Japan
we have one specific icon,
or for Europe, or the US,
we have other icons.
And also, we have changed the
icon inside the same region.
So for example, now we launched
a new version of the game
that we have-- "Alliances."
And we changed the icon from
the previous one to a new one.
But when we do these
kind of changes,
we are worried about the brand.
I mean, is a good point.
So we try to maintain
the essence of the icon,
keeping the core of the
icon, and adding a loop,
saying to the users, hey, there
is something new in the game.
So we take care of the brand,
making changes on the icon,
but carefully.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: All right.
One question here.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
I'm Alexis from Republic Labs.
A question, maybe
more for Andres.
The price localization
part, how important
is it, the price localization?
I mean, for example, I'm
thinking of a country,
like Latin America, where maybe
certain games have a hard time
monetizing.
Do you see a really important
effect, not just on revenues,
but also maybe on retention?
And as part of that, if you
have a multiplayer game, which
is your case, do you see
maybe players communicating
and complaining, hey, I'm
paying this in the US,
and you're paying that?
And how risky is that?
ANDRES BOU: We have not seen
that-- users complaining
from one region to another.
So what we normally do, we--
I mean, for example, LATAM,
it's 20% of our DAU, and
it's 4% of our revenues.
If you check the payments--
the type of payments
that they have
there-- it's totally
different to what
we have in Europe
or what we have in the US.
So we have done
changes on pricing.
We have seen improvements
from 10% to 25%
in some regions
and some markets.
So I would say it's
important to have the prices.
I wouldn't do it
at the beginning.
I would launch the game,
see which is the ARPPU,
the A-R-P-P-U, that
you are seeing,
and then do improvements to try
to boost revenues by 10%, 15%,
20% of [INAUDIBLE].
REGINA CHAMMA:
Just to add here, I
think-- we've been
actually doing some price
experiments in the region.
And definitely, this
is something new
in the emerging markets.
I'm not talking only for
Brazil and Latin America,
but all the emerging markets.
Google actually is
investing quite a lot.
We are putting not only the
technology there, but really
people there.
We are spending
consumer marketing.
We are really educating these
users to buy digital goods.
We are not in Japan,
that people are
used to buy digital
goods-- or US, or UK.
These people are just learning
how to use smart phones
and engage with digital
goods, or games, or apps,
so we need actually
to educate that.
We just launched local forms of
payments in Brazil and Mexico,
for instance.
So until last year,
we didn't have--
only international credit cards
were accepted in the store.
So this is something that-- it's
a big [INAUDIBLE] that we've
been doing, not only in Latin
America, but all the emerging
markets.
And we're going to be pushing
that, educating the users.
But I definitely believe
changing prices, specifically
for some markets, are important.
It's very hard for you, because
there are a lot of markets, no?
So I would recommend,
maybe, prioritize.
OK, what is my-- maybe
20% of the installments
are coming from that market.
Is that a market there
that I have to explore?
And if yes, try to find out
what is the right pricing point.
What is the user behavior of
that market, should really
be your strategy.
But this is something
that we're going
to be investing quite a lot
in the next months and years.
And if you think that
most of these emerging
markets-- like 80% isn't
right-- it's a big thing.
We are really
working to make sure
that users understand that
they can consume in the store.
I think that is our approach.
ANDRES BOU: Also,
apart from pricing--
[LAUGHTER]
We have some more time?
Or not?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Go ahead.
We need to finish that.
But if you have any
comment, then you can--
ANDRES BOU: No, I
know Alexis, so I
can chat with him later on.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Ask him, then, later.
So all right.
So thank you, for joining us.
OK.
Let's finish the
go global sessions.
But if you have any questions,
then please reach out us,
then ask the questions.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you, and then give the
big applause to the panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]